-Coming this spring,
Broadway is back
with a new musical that captures
the spirit of our times.
-Susan?
Oh, right.
She's in Colorado till Monday.
♪ Chicken, chicken, chicken ♪
♪ Eatin' all the chicken
in my house ♪
-It's "By Yourself:
The Musical,"
a tribute to the little songs
we all sing when
we're by ourselves.
-♪ Plates, oh, my God, girl ♪
♪ What did you do last night? ♪
♪ You covered in mess ♪
-♪ Oh, no, another Amazon box ♪
♪ What's in this box? ♪
♪ What did I buy? ♪
Ha!
♪ Some envelopes ♪
-That's right, the little songs
that make you think,
"Am I okay?"
-♪ Look at my hand ♪
♪ It's walkin' like a person ♪
♪ Walkin' like a person
on the other hand ♪
♪ Now it's kickin' ♪
♪ Kickin' like it's dancin' ♪
♪ I think it's for the best that
I live alone ♪
-Audiences agree, "Finally,
a musical we can relate to."
Broadway.com says, "Not sure why
that cost money to see,
but I loved it," and
"The New York Times" raves --
♪ Typin', typin', typin',
tappin', tappin', tappin' ♪
♪ At the keys,
I'm the New York Times ♪
And, of course, no musical is
complete without drama.
-♪ Hello ♪
♪ It's bread ♪
♪ I forgot that you were there
and now you have to go be dead ♪
♪ See you on the other side ♪
-It's got surprises.
-♪ Everybody's on the Zoom
talkin' out of their ass ♪
-Sorry, could you mute yourself?
-Yes. I apologize.
-And don't worry, it's got hits.
-♪ When you touch me like this ♪
♪ And you touch me like this
and like that ♪
♪ I'm insane ♪
-But mostly it's 10-second
ditties that do not rhyme
about whatever a person
is looking at.
-♪ Yogurt, what the hell
are you? ♪
♪ My best guess is ♪
♪ Jiggly milk ♪
-It's "By Yourself:
The Musical,"
a truly modern musical that
teaches us
we might not be so alone
after all.
-♪ We are in love ♪
-♪ This bread's not so bad ♪
-♪ We're gettin' married ♪
-♪ You're like wet stuff with
Jello ♪
-♪ Too bad no one can hear me ♪
-♪ 'Cause damn, I can sing ♪
-♪ And you're the best at ♪
♪ Doing the thing ♪
-"By Yourself: The Musical."
Come on, you know you do it.